justin trudeau n'a pas l'intention de
mettre en place des mesures de
représailles en réponse aux accusations
d'espionnage contre les canadiens
michael pieper et michael cover it par
les autorités chinoises le secrétaire
d'état américain mike pomme paix aux
appuis le canada ces accusations dit ils
ont des motivations politiques qui sont
totalement infondées les etats-unis se
joignent au canada pour demander à pékin
la libération immédiate des deux hommes
et rejette l'utilisation de ces
détentions et justifie pour contraindre
le canada avec nous ce soir patrick
leblond professeur à l'école d'affaires
publiques et internationales de
l'université d'ottawa spécialiste
notamment des questions d'économie
politique internationale
bonsoir patrick leblond bonsoir ce
client est ce que l'appui comme ça des
états unis au canada dans ce dossier-là
pourrait changer quelque chose
pour l'instant c'est un appui symbolique
comme c'est le cas depuis le début il
faut se rappeler que c'est à la suite de
la demande des états unis d'extrader
madame wang [ __ ] du canada du canada au
moment où elle était de passage à
vancouver qui a commencé tout le bal
mais depuis ce temps là disons les
américains ont surtout offert une appui
symbolique alors que bien sur plusieurs
personnes auraient aimé que il retire
d'ailleurs la demande d'extradition
parce que on pouvait penser qu'à ce
moment là elles vont elles pourraient
rentrer en chine et éventuellement
monsieur pas voir monsieur couvrir
pourrait rentrer au canada et donc
mettre fin la haute tension diplomatique
actuelle mais les américains n'en vois
aucun signal comme quoi ils pourraient
avoir l'intention de retirer leur
demande d'extradition
non pas du tout certain moment donné
monsieur trump avait évoqué l'idée qu'
il pourrait y avoir un deal donc en fait
il avait lui-même politisé toute la
sphère
mais bien sûr c'est son il s'est
focalisé sur tout sur son accord
commercial et c'est ça qui prime est
surtout et même d'ailleurs ce qui
ressort du livre de monsieur john bolton
en ce moment semblé confirmer que
c'était cet accord là entre la chine et
états unis
cet accord commercial qui primait sur
tout toutes les relations en fait
etats unis chine qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour nos relations commerciales
entre le canada et la chine que cette
histoire perdure que même moines jour
reste au canada est toujours sous cette
menace d'extradition la demande est
toujours en place les accusations
d'espionnage maintenant contre les deux
maiko ça veut dire quoi pour nos
relations économiques et commerciales
avec la chine pas disons que si pour
fonder ça ça ne veut rien dire c'est à
dire que le fait que les deux mike
aurait été formellement accusés ne
change rien comme tel à la relation
commerciale
en fait tout ce que ça fait c'est que le
gros nuage noir qui plane au dessus de
de ses relations bon ce métier et risque
de se maintenir encore pour pour assez
longtemps
donc si vous croyez avoir des
représailles parce qu'on a on a parlé de
représailles de la chine
on a accusé la chine d'imposer des
représailles sur le port notamment sur
le canola mais en retour est ce que le
canada pourrait imposer des représailles
à la chine le canada pourrait imposer
des représailles le danger c'est que si
canal en impose des représailles
qu'est ce que la chaîne va faire elles
vont imposer des représailles et l'on se
retrouve un peu dans une course vers
vers le comme on dit les américains les
anglais disent risque de bornes dans une
course vers le fond et qui va faire mal
à tout le monde on regarde même la
guerre commerciale entre la chine et
états unis où les américains ont imposé
des droits de douane aux chinois les
chinois imposer des droits de douane aux
américains et ils continuent un peu de
se taper sur la tête comme ça jusqu'à
temps qu'ils aient eu un accord mais il
faudra voir qu'est-ce que cet accord là
va donner pour l'instant pas grand chose
mais c'est certain que ça fait mal à
l'économie américaine mais ça fait mal à
l'économie chinoise
alors c'est clair que pour moi
le fait d'imposer des représente
certainement commerciale de la part du
canada envers les chiffres en chine
risque de nous faire plus mal qu'autre
chose sans atteindre l'objectif cultive
mans devrait être de ramener les deux
mycal au canada on ne fait pas le poids
dans un sens il ya plus de danger de
perdre et de ne rien gagner ce qu'on
veut gagner en déclenchant une guerre
commerciale ou en coupant des liens
diplomatiques
absolument on n'a rien à gagner en
faisant ça si on regarde du côté des
américaines qui ont une économie encore
beaucoup plus importante que celle de la
chine
jusqu'à maintenant ils ont rien gagné
non plus dans leur guerre commerciale
avec avec les chinois au contraire alors
faut vraiment se demander jusqu'à quel
point est-ce que de confronter la chine
est d'entrer dans des représailles et en
se tapant les uns sur les autres
est-ce qu'on va vraiment arriver à notre
objectif je ne le crois pas parce que
y'a rien qui démontre que c'est le cas
de l'autre côté il faut démontrer à la
chine que de les représenter par exemple
avec justement les arrestations
arbitraires de monsieur covering de
monsieur spa mort n'ont rien donné non
plus et que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas la
façon dont le canada et le reste du
monde fonctionne justement qu'il n'a pas
des gens innocents pour des débuts
purement politique
alors donc mais il faut continuer
justement le dialogue diplomatique
certainement il faut ça ne veut pas dire
d'accepter ce que la chaîne fait au
contraire le premier ministre le dit et
d'autres le disent il faut il faut dire
à la chine que c'est inacceptable
heureusement les américains disent aussi
est bon ce qu'on peut espérer c'est que
de cette façon là ça nuise à la
réputation de la chine à travers le
monde et qui éventuellement ça peut
faire pression mais en ce moment le
canada est vraiment pris entre l'arbre
et les corses
que ce soit les états unis d'un côté et
la chine de l'autre et on est un peu mal
pris c'est certain que des représailles
sur aux moines ne sont pas la solution
film
accenture et huawei officiellement dans
le développement du 5 g au canada là est
ce que ça pourrait avoir un effet
positif ça j'en doute parce que jusqu'à
maintenant
le volet chinois de façon officieuse ont
lié le comme madame mengue avec le lait
les cas de monsieur pas avoir et
monsieur covering alors ce qui semble la
seule chose qui sembleraient les
satisfaire à ce moment là c'est de
relâcher madame un bon on sait qu
apparemment légalement le ministre la
justice aurait le pouvoir de le faire
c'est ce que les chinois de monde
est ce qu'on peut voir c'est
qu'effectivement la pression qui misent
sur le canada à travers ces arrestations
arbitraires
c'est d'en arriver à ça en présumant que
les américains ne vont pas retirer leur
demande d'extradition
mais est-ce que d'accepter huawei dans
la nouvelle génération 5 g en termes de
télécommunications je doute que ça soit
suffisant pour régler l'histoire et
qu'on puisse retourner à des relations
harmonieuses entre la chine et le canada
c'est ce qu'on verra bien on suit ça de
très près patrick leblanc merci merci
monsieur fillion revoir